this guy is on one second of coke it is
one second immediately he's so yaked out
yeah and the cops are following him and
it's unreal dude he's in Florida he
hasn't slept in 70 days he's definitely
in Florida
[Music]
awesome
it's making me so uncontrolled like the
really
sensual thing you're doing at the end
what like when you go uh like it sounds
very like
personal
right yeah I know but I don't like it
because
yeah that that I get you're doing that
for the audience no I'm doing it for
honestly I'm doing it for me oh okay
well I'm the only one here next to you
so it seems like you're doing it for me
and that's why it makes me uncomfortable
well I'm just get it I'm getting it
going
yeah that's not the right song I sing
when you're getting it going though
what is that song
Stevie what that's Stevie Stevie Wonder
yeah
it is what's the what's the name of that
song
yeah it is
I don't know what it is and I don't care
I I don't know why I share more
there you go dude I don't like I don't
know why uh that song is stuck in my
head literally haven't heard it in years
you think I heard it in the background
somewhere wait wait long ago think about
this all the time
do we get the songs
stuck the ones we get in our head why do
we get this because we hear them
maybe not though what right well so my
question to you is did I hear that
somewhere even quickly passing by and I
just didn't realize it because that
could very well be true that could be
and that would be in my head but uh also
because that does happen the brain is
really mysterious and weird and things
pop into it like by association because
the other day you know what was in my
head for no reason
yeah yeah yeah it's all right it's all
right it's all right so worried you know
[Laughter]
never worried about anything in his life
but yeah the lyrics would imply he's
definitely been just he's worried he's
definitely been worried about where
sunglasses were sometimes
um he definitely has someone who manages
just his sunglasses when he goes on tour
that would be so awesome God that would
be so awesome if you had crazy crazy
money what would you have uh
or just yeah yeah I guess so yeah like
actually like a chef no ice maybe a chef
probably a chef but something I've
specifically always thought I wanted was
I
I hate to sound like a boomer but I hate
these and I want someone to follow me
around who has it for me and every time
there's an alert that I've given him a
specific criteria that are deemed worthy
of alerting me for yeah he gives it to
me it would be he would be giving it to
you all day long because we text so much
or she but yeah you guys wouldn't be on
priority dude you would just would but
like the lifeline thread might not be
you know got it yeah yeah that's true
wow really you thought about this I've
thought about that yeah I would have it
like stupid money though
not like uh well I mean that's honestly
not if I had like eight million dollars
I'm talking about like a billionaire you
know if you were Larry uh what's his
name from Black Stone or whatever it's
called Blackberry Olson Black Wall what
the hell BlackRock is that Larry Ellison
no Larry Fleck or something what the
hell is his name
no anyway it doesn't matter
um
but yeah so okay well I would have for
sure
um chef yes driver easy oh really you
love driving now I do but I would still
have my driver like riding in the
passenger seat hey yeah we're gonna go
this place now I do love driving I do
actually love driving but I would still
have a driver in case I just didn't want
to interesting yeah would the driver
like live at your in that in the car in
the house like that you in the car
outside some drivers like make them
sleep out have their families live on
the premises of the wealthy person they
uh that's so weird like you ever seen
that movie Sabrina I mean
or top favorite films that's a remake
but yeah oh right right right yeah but
did they do it in the remake too I don't
know I don't think I ever saw the room
table the original one well the original
here's the thing about Serena and other
movies make that movie right
there's no way that's cool there are
many great old movies Sabrina one of the
more famous ones isn't good it sucks
ballisimos I don't like why would you
remake a movie that sucks no one knows
well you'd make remake a movie that
sucks Belize the most to make it good
right but here's I think that that's a
good idea
you're right but here's the thing uh-huh
William Holden and Humphrey Bogart are
always going to be better than Harrison
Ford who's good and Greg Kinnear okay
fair enough big mistake to ever put Greg
in your name sorry Greek here I love you
but you're not like you're not William
Holden you're not a leading man you're
not even cool you're like a funny guy
that's around you know I think that Greg
Kinnear is a really good actor dude
I think he's a really good actor I mean
what what was he good Talk Soup I mean
he's fine no he I think he's really good
he's good and um As Good As It Gets he's
really good in that
he's good and stuck on you you really
thought it's part of Matt Damon I stuck
on you's funny yeah you're right kid I
don't know he had a minute though that
he was like the lead in movies and there
was he had the weirdest not a good
reason he had the weirdest career
to movies he was the first guy to kind
of ruin everything you know oh wow the
first guy to ruined everything Greg
Kinnear yep that's a hell of a it went
Sir Mix A Lot then then
I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm joking I
just thought of a silly name but yeah
Greg canier
he's a great actor okay I think he's got
Oscar in him I guess I chose the wrong
guy yeah to watch your mouth I'm in the
wrong company to start uh but Sabrina is
I am a big
I do not watch movies that are a
person's name I think that's that's a
huge it's gonna be a lazy movie uh it's
a huge cop-out I there's there are
movies that are just someone's name that
I like that always hate yeah that too I
don't oh oh Sabrina yeah
who the [__] is Sabrina right yep well
we'll find out we'll watch a movie I
guess but also I that doesn't make you
want to watch a movie because I don't
know who that is already explain
something about Sabrina Sabrina and her
or just the thing that is about her and
then you when you see the movie you'll
say oh that's someone named Sabrina and
she has these qualities yeah why we
don't know anything from the title the
worst is when it's a full name though
honestly the worst is when it's just a
first name I disagree I think it's worse
when it's a first and last name like
what Michael Clayton terrible title I
mean it's a great movie actually but I
get it I know
what about
um I feel like they arrive at that when
they've exhausted yeah exactly so stupid
there's always a better title always
always and the title if it's a name is
so it's just so blonking lazy it's also
so boring you made it someone made up
that name
Michael Clayton could be Pierre Wilson
okay and they could name the movie
Pierre Wilson and it would be the exact
same amount of good the title would make
the amount same exact amount of sense
but it would just be his name in the
movie is Pierre Wilson dude I met
somebody the other day I can't remember
if there's a sick name I can't remember
if I met them or if I knew them already
but they actually said that Michael
Clayton is the best movie they've ever
seen in their life you know what I've
I've spoken to people that really let's
think that I did not know it was that
good well I most people don't think it's
the best but some but the fact that
somebody thinks Michael Clayton is the
best movie of all time I was what I was
like what I wish I remembered who it was
there are absolutely people really who
think that yeah yeah wow yeah crazy
right I only saw half of it
oh why would you do that I mean that's
actually a genuinely good movie to see
the part where they uh spoiler alert
kill Tom Wilkinson no but he's such a
honestly you talk about good acting he's
never been better than he is in that
movie really and the the scene in which
they really they he's like there's like
a hit put out on him but because he's he
won't shut up he's babbling about the
lawsuit that's how he's supposedly for
yeah man yeah like monsanto's type
company that did bad stuff and he's like
telling the truth and they can't have
that yeah I know they can't so all in
one shot they break into his apartment
and kill him and take him out and it's
like so crazy like uh efficient well
it's just really upsetting oh really
yeah you know what someone think about
when someone dies all dramatic in a
movie yeah it's so distant reality that
you can watch it and be entertained when
someone just is like
yeah it's so much more upsetting because
you know that's how it happened I know
dude I saw a Thing Once where somebody
got shot in the head like uh you know
was the thing I didn't even mean to see
but yeah dude they just they don't
there's none of like this [__] no no no
they just go they completely go it's
crazy they collapse yeah yeah oh gosh
dude enjoy your Sunday yeah but it's
just so bad how about people who like
watching Faces of Death I know I don't
like that at all if I'm gonna get shot
though and I see it coming I'm gonna
jump back to make it more cinematic
while I get shot I'm gonna jump up above
the bullet so the Bullet doesn't even
hit me oh you could just
and you did that and you still got shot
and your last word was weak well I
wouldn't say we if I was getting shut up
yeah yeah yeah yeah you might say we
gotta go if it was you and other people
there yeah maybe uh-huh so don't count
you don't count it you know you never
know right oh man what you want to go
you want to get into a thing I do I'm
thinking about sad things now I need to
get it oh all right well let's do the
thing let's talk about it here
hey how's it going Chris and Matt uh so
I was the guy who called in the other
week about the sundials at Goodwill
buying stuff from Goodwill oh yeah the
only reason I said that Chris is because
that's your joke you used to say that uh
you would always buy sundials for
people's birthdays as like a joke like
if somebody said oh were you getting
like someone for their birthday you
would say oh I'm getting them Sundial
that's the only reason I said that yeah
I just wanted to clear that error on
that one I'm calling in because I have
this issue regarding license plates and
people get customized license plates on
like Teslas or soccer moms doing a lot
you know like if they have a family
they'll put on the bag like PTY of five
right like Party of Five or if they're a
Tesla they'll put like sun powered this
really annoys me and I don't know why
and I would like to hear y'all's input
customized license plates should we be
doing this what what do y'all think yeah
I I think that they're unless like
there's exceptions right like don't get
customized license plate if you're a
soccer mom like that's just
kids to school and back and forth like
no oh don't do that if you're a
businessman and you have a convertible
you can get it dude I couldn't couldn't
disagree more dude you you know what you
actually don't even know that you don't
believe what you're saying I haven't
said anything yet bro you said you
disagree with me and you agree with me
but I haven't said my thing yet okay
which is that
it's not okay if you think your license
plate makes you look cool it's not okay
if you think your license plate is funny
it is okay if it says something really
dumb on your license plate no dude you I
was right what I said okay but I'm right
you agree with me and you just don't
even realize it what is the businessman
on the Corvette have on his on his
license plate
like if a guy drove by in a uh uh like a
Z3 Roadster okay you know what that is
yeah notice E3 is okay because I know
about cars okay so and and it was and it
said something like
bees man
love it yeah but Biz man isn't what I
thought you were gonna say dude
obviously Biz man if the guy knows it's
stupid the problem is you don't know if
that guy because it's cool if he thinks
it's cool it's funny but it's not like
he's asking something else I get it I
get it
okay
if like
I mean no that's not a that's not a good
example bizman for someone else but I
mean bizman I would laugh at for sure oh
the guy says [__] we got to take her
dude please can I get that only other
seat in this car but thinking about the
actual person he was so terrible to be
around oh yeah that's true there are a
lot of cool people not even cool that's
the wrong word there are other people
that will will walk by or drive by and
be like Oh my God look at that guy and
you like kind of are sighted about them
that you realize will be terrible at
terrible Hangar routers yes for sure
yeah I don't how many friends do you
have
um
I mean that's tough like people I what's
a friend like that's a good question I
would say my instinct is to say a very
close group smaller amount
and that's not true I mean some I know
so many people that I'm in touch with a
lot that I consider my friends so so
many just endless amounts nobody's ever
had more friends than someone like me
you know yeah
um
no I'd say good good friends like 50 10
15. yeah cool I would probably say
around the same but I don't count I'm
your brother no you don't care yeah okay
cool but I'm a good friend I would be
but still 10 15 because there's a five
person
thing there so it could swing from 10 to
15. you whether you're in there or not
wouldn't really make that much of a
difference [__] man you're good at math
like that so yeah I don't I think for a
general rule no I would never get one
would you uh no no I guess no I would
not okay all right
okay next one
hey Chris hey Ma
uh both of y'all uh blah blah blah blah
flash feel about how much you guys have
changed my life anyways
um two things that need advice is on and
they're both work related one my
co-worker eats Panda Express every
single [__] day he comes in with his
Panda Express his orange chicken
orange chicken how do I get to stop
smells so bad I work in a three-story
building people from the first floor
come up to take a [__] in the third
floors bathroom what do I do about that
please I'm tired of smelling stank ass
[__] it's awkward because they don't
even women are weird when they poop why
do women not make any noise like I know
what you're doing in there Sandra
[__] silently sitting in there for
five ass minutes so weird anyways what
do I do thanks love you bye and I also
suck on Mattel's crank oh dude that is
uh a great length of video submission it
is and it's also a two and she fit two
in there yeah it was really good what
was the first one
dude yeah
but honestly bring a loaded gun to the
to work and just slide it over to him
and be like here use that on yourself
it'll go much quicker
yeah I mean that's killing yourself
that's
disgusting every day is fast food I do
not care what oh yes well yeah of course
people don't think of it like that
though they think they're like arrest
dude yes absolutely but it's also even
fast Chinese food yeah no I know that's
disgusting yeah but so is all fast food
and that is particularly disgusting I
knew it I knew a dude that uh ate fast
food three times a day
and he'd be like yeah I just eat fast
food three times a day I just like it
and I'm like that's not good did you
know it wasn't good
you just didn't care he was fat
well did he know that that was why
because a lot of people don't dude
that's still not an entire population
understood thing which is crazy and then
another time and then that guy was
friends with another guy you know it is
I'm not gonna air him out but I was like
he hadn't had sex for so long and he
hadn't dated for so long and I was like
why don't you just like maybe you're
um
maybe you're uh uh
ugly no no no no maybe your uh threshold
what do you call it maybe your sex drive
no no no no like when somebody
is shooting too high maybe you're
oh you should broaden your
horizons extraordinate broaden your no
like you're going out you're trying for
two hot chicks you're shooting above you
yeah okay yeah whatever that is God damn
it what the [__] is it I don't think
there is it I don't think that's a thing
no it is punching above your weight yeah
but not that that is a way to say it yes
but that isn't what I was going for so
punching above your weight but hold on
maybe you you need to I think that's
what he's thinking it's punching above
your weight no that's not what I'm
thinking that's not what I'm thinking
because he said it I
a guy at that at an auction hold on hold
on hold on maybe you're maybe you should
maybe you should God standards yes whoa
what did he say yes what is that maybe
you should load not have to use your
lower your standards you should not say
yes dude you redeemed yourself you still
like the terrifier movie but [__] yeah
dude you still got bad taste but yeah
you still got bad taste in films but
[__] yeah came through with the Lord you
lower your standards I said over here I
saw a terrifier sticker on a car no on
the way over here you saw terrifier
sticker on the car it's spreading yep
what if you looked at a car and it was a
guy
so hold on
um now he's he's chasing him down trying
to hunt again
becomes friends with the only other
person who likes terrifier okay go
um so so that's just stupid dude I mean
not more people more two people like it
I mean I know yeah okay so don't all
right everyone knows that yeah okay it
made a bunch of money so
um
so he and then he said he got so
frustrated I was like because because
sometimes you might meet somebody you're
open to yeah yeah they're pretty but who
knows and then you become more attracted
to them of course
yeah yeah and he said I've told you this
but he said I I will not hook up with
some standard [__] I will not put
some Center [__] dude and I do know
what you're talking about yeah and I was
like oh like he was so frustrated and I
was like it was crazy dude wow
but some things are [__] dude that's
how he said it I mean he needs yeah I
know deep therapy yeah wow so
that is wild I could totally see it yeah
and still not going out and still not
going out with anyone he will not he
will not hook up with substandard
[__] though I don't like them yeah
yeah no [__] you don't like it who likes
that how old is he when he did that
yeah unacceptable yeah
um so that was funny when that [__]
happened and I stand by it and uh I
think that honestly if you eat Panda ex
that's
dude that's terrible
what do you do about it I think you
actually have the right to say something
I think you're disgusting just and also
say it smells it smells really bad can
you go to the first floor yeah because
other people come up to the third floor
to take you know what you did send them
back down to the first floor no even it
out you know what you do it already
smells in the bathroom go eat the Panda
Express in the shitty third floor
bathroom
and just you know One Stop Shop for
smelling Badness right but who I don't
think that guy's gonna be down with
going into the bathroom that smells like
[__] to eat his lunch
how is it in there you're pissing how's
the food
um so hold on yeah and I I feel like
well that's I don't how about dude
there's people that go to different
levels to take a bath I want to focus on
that part of that but it's a thing
though
I'm gonna go upstairs I gotta go to the
bathroom who does there's a bathroom
right here who does that oh I have clear
memories of people doing it oh okay yeah
I mean I don't our uncle did it once at
our house
oh well I guess they do it because I
think they think it's gonna smell right
okay but I know wherever the closest
bathroom is if you do that and no one is
if if you do it where
if you want to go to a different floor
of the domicile in which you are
currently yeah existing with others and
there's no one else at that Level
Society yeah then that's a respect thing
I cannot understand if there are people
on that level you're just making other
people smell your [__] it's not better
it's still making like that's actually
Ruder right yeah oh I see what you're
saying yeah so it's like if they were
gonna go to the third floor nobody was
on the third floor of course that makes
sense that's respectful if you're gonna
go to the third floor there are just
other people I'm sure if she thinks it's
annoying other people notice it so when
that guy comes off the elevator as soon
as you see him tell everybody before him
have everybody go oh here we go that's a
good that would be awesome shaming in
this instance is and this is very viable
very viable yeah that's a good idea when
he gets off the elevator ding if you
know the person who shits ding this
person's gonna take a big [__] it's
gonna smell really bad as they walk by
going to the bathroom I mean yeah that's
a little more aggressive what did you
say oh here we go oh but that's not
enough look at it though but then then
you you gotta yeah room though to go
somewhere okay you know what I'm saying
you do that you see what his face looks
like okay and if he still does it yeah
then you go oh here comes the [__]
guy's gonna [__] in our [__] third
floor right you probably can't get rid
of for that he's probably doing
something that he shouldn't be doing
honest if the company really thought
about it yeah or is it a different
company on the first floor which would
be crazy dude if it's like a Coke and
then a Pepsi on the top and it's just
part of the soda Wars
um
and the guy's eating Panda Express too
all sorts of [__] bad [__]
ah man hey you're disgusting dude yeah I
mean I would if I knew the person well
enough I would it's not the same person
eating the Panda Express that goes up no
because that's the person two persons
are also on the third floor all right
well we figured it out and we're walking
into the devices management about the
[__] too if you want to yeah or just
go to HR and say he's molesting you make
everyone
put up signs and say please do the
dookies on your own floor what if that
was the sign throughout the course
everyone remember dookie on your floor
is accepted and only that on the
elevator I mean it's worded so terribly
Duty on your floor is only accepted
is accepted on your floor and only that
I said you did say that okay all I can
do is [__] all right next one
hi Matt hi Chris hi Chris I've been a
baby for a really long time Matt I think
I'm just in love with you so hey okay
here's my situation I live alone but I
have these really cool downstairs
neighbors
um and I know for a fact that they smoke
weed every single night and that we're
cool like we've exchanged numbers and
stuff
um
but my question is
can I text them to like smoke weed with
me sometime because I do I don't smoke
often like them but I when I do want to
smoke weed I don't want to do it alone
but is it like crossing a like an
apartment neighbor boundary like does it
make it weird if they don't want to and
then like
like I don't know you know they don't
want to come out of their house or
something
let me know I'm just like Chris and that
I think everyone hates me until like I
know that they don't uh so
yeah so uh I would love your advice so
she she basically it's not that she
wants to even what a lovely person be
high or smoke weed yeah she certainly
seems like it but she um what has doubts
so you know what if she just closed the
computer and then she just goes
um no but she
she just wants to like partake in the
time you know like she's like ah dude
that sounds fun just smoking and choking
and hitting that [__] you know what I
mean so chocolate Thai just taking a
little puff of that sticky icky so if
I'm smoking weed ooh damn good [__] okay
you know okay but I'm just saying it's
better if it's purple it means it's good
I've heard that Justin McKinnon told me
that when I was younger wow Jessica was
smoking weed when you knew him he knew
about weed yeah wasn't it McKibben
McKinnon Jordan
that was him right yeah dude God damn
dude have you talked about that Marco do
you know about that
wait wasn't it McKibben it was [__]
McKinnon dude why are you saying it like
that because I already said I didn't
know you answered okay you [__] kid
dude absolutely I absolutely take it
down you're too mad you'll absolutely
what you're just too mad though dude
you're too mad though so hold on you
asked a question didn't listen for the
answer or what I did I did but you asked
I thought you skipped this answer just
him about do you think okay okay wow
okay all right so it's Justin McKibben
no no no and and he would uh and we were
it was his birthday and I went
everyone's gonna sleep over I didn't
sleep over because I I didn't want to
sleep over because you're scared I was
scared at that moment I would get scared
yeah because he loved Freddy Krueger
right so oh
what kind of story comes out so um Chris
Siegel was kind of smelly right no oh
okay I'm thinking of somebody
died died we're gonna Bernie so
um so so he said uh so we were watching
on his birthday we were watching the
Bulls play and he loved the Chicago
Bulls I remember that I used to wear
Jersey for no reason he loved the
Chicago Bulls you know like a [__]
jacket a lot of people are like that the
Bulls were a thing the Bulls were and
the Cowboys are outside Chicago Cowboys
in the 90s both of those teams in the
90s people could be like in Alabama
being like I love the Bulls like for no
Steelers are like the two but anyway
um
so what nothing
Irish nothing nothing so so he so we're
watching
the balls the Bulls yeah starting a
laugh and so he doubles and he said he
Jordan did a thing you know either slam
dunked or was on his way and he said
Jordan with the Slime and nobody did
anything about it because he was just
doing it yeah and then he just did it so
many times every time Jordan got the
ball he would just say Jordan with the
Slime damn that's cool and there were
like 12 people there and I was like
all right I didn't have anyone who could
lock eyes with him be like what the [__]
is this guy doing I think he said
anything about it it's probably the
first time I ever thought about looking
at someone else and being like the [__]
is this guy doing you know I mean it's
so young Jordan with the Slime dude how
did I we didn't how insane is it
how I am so blessed and I mean this that
I went to that party for that memory
that has lived with me yeah for uh 30
years
and I have been doing Jordan with the
slam for 30 years and it has brought me
joy more than 30 years really weird and
I would love for Justin McKinnon
to reach out
we should have him on the show I think I
tried to find him once but
um yeah dude and I think quadir was the
only one that was like you keep saying
Jordan with the slam I don't but that's
a quadir quadir was really really tiny
guy with glasses damn yeah I don't
remember him at all
but yeah I remember most your friends
Teddy
Omar disguise I haven't thought about
Teddy in so long Teddy was the Omar Omar
Omar uh Omar Pitt now Omar there was no
more pits I'm talking about no more to
hold Omar hold I still I have kept in
touch with up until last I mean this is
so boring for everybody but anyway no
let's go through
everybody's younger sister Tatiana was a
migraine and Kevin uh Nelson okay
let's go to the next one
okay cool all right the nice guys on
coke so much I cannot believe for sure I
can't believe how much the first second
of that guy was on so much coke it's
unbelievable and so stay tuned for that
being chased by cops
Wally made the video of submission and
the submission the advice is nothing
about that yeah okay all right cool so
this woman so what do you do about
pancakes and then you can't hear if I'm
smoking weed with the person I live with
and oh you don't even answer it and a
neighbor that I like texts me and says
oh I can smell the weed can I come over
and smoke with you
I'm all about it I'm super stoked I'm
happy I say yes come over and it's it's
more fun because that person's there so
this is a good thing for her to figure
out if somebody actually really likes
her you're saying right if the person if
I don't like the person I not only am
like oh no I'm like oh I feel like
intruded upon I feel like I can't smoke
anymore and they're gonna smell it and
know and they're going to want to come
over it's a big thing it's like it's
like a big leap basically asking them to
do it but the thing is if they're down
for it they really really will be happy
about you joining them if they're not
down for it they'll be like stressed out
every time they put a joint to the lips
so it's a judgment call I'm assuming
they like you because you seem like
someone that is generally liked by
people so my guess would be yeah ask
them but ask them like in between
sessions right like be like I've noticed
you guys smoke I love to smoke ask me
over next time you do it don't do it
while they're stoned because that's the
other thing you could freak people out
when they're stoned and they could be
like uh
is she a narc is she a cop not paying
attention
I was trying to think of something this
is what you do you legit don't do any of
that
next no I'm kidding you you you you you
just
you don't ask they they're your
downstairs neighbors open your window
and just
[Music]
and then and then and then and then go
pause it and reach it I don't want to
say what
okay oh sorry I thought you said
something
and then no I didn't I no that would
definitely I would understand that as oh
would you
um do you want to come smoke but that
would be so roundabout and so weird dude
even if you did even if the person did
understand as you're suggesting
now that I would get
[Laughter]
and then close it what yeah
no I didn't say anything I just oh oh
what are you guys doing
play this out we're just we're just
hanging out smoking weed dude that's so
funny I was just playing Bob Marley I
love I love I love weed that's [__]
hilarious anyway dude I'm gonna go no no
no no no no okay see ya good night good
night
you planted the seed
right next time this time take it take
it for the team the next time they go
they they light it up dude
and then [__] you do it again it was
a different song dude light it up when
they light it up no dude no this is all
wrong all you do here we go when they
light it up just
get all these hip-hop songs and then I
just start with something else yeah dude
that was the thing back then
um
get a chronic uh here's
the deal
you don't have to ask them while they're
stoned
ask them next time you run into them or
just text them during the day sometime
and be like hey next time you guys smoke
I would love to come out yes no
absolutely yes even because then they'll
still they still may be oh no you could
still feel giving them the chance to not
feel intruded upon by being like hey I
smell it but I know but if you say to
them hey dude do you guys want to smoke
weed tonight
yeah that might be good yeah but yeah
okay oh we're gonna do it anyway come on
down our house totally to that yeah or
next two yeah nah and then if they smoke
anyway then they know that oh it's just
their thing [__] yeah dude I come up
with great advices dude I mean
what's that song name that's the one I
wanted to use I never know that song
name dude that's um it's the d-o double
G
let's just keep going until we get the
title
next episode dude on The Chronic 2000
right yeah
Casey casa next episode
is it really
he's probably wrong oh there we go dude
that's what it is bro hey dude they
start smoking weed and just open your
window
dude
as soon as you smell it dude I used to
Freestyle to that song in High School
there's nothing whiter honestly isn't
that hilarious dude yo yo dude one time
with Mitchell we were we were
freestyling and he goes
babies is the ladies dude and I I had to
pull over bro babies is the lady I had
to pull over you know you get so caught
up you just start yeah dude he said
babies
is the ladies dude that's really funny I
had to pull over and that is another
Jordan with the Slime I always think of
it dude yeah pulling out two of them
right now so yeah dude I love those
things you never know when they're gonna
happen you don't
know I wish more of them happened but I
guess that's what makes them so special
exactly last one that happened I don't
know sometimes you need time to gestate
for sure yeah you know for sure for sure
for sure I remember the last one that
happened what
I think what was it this look at this
some was it that one no no actually you
know that one recent I think so we maybe
I've talked about that
what was the game we were playing I
forget the name of the game it was
something like taboo or whatever though
where you get a card and it's the thing
you need to convey and then there's the
words under it that you can't say to try
to convey it right yes and my dad got
magician Eddie was like because there's
a clock on it
and he couldn't think of it fast enough
so he just he goes look at this
that's cool it was that's good it was
absolutely dude hello at that same time
he hit his [__] foot too which is
great he tripped a little bit [__]
families dude yeah oh we what a what a
time what was the last one you had
think about these back at home oh a guy
I know do I know about this one no oh
man I love when I know okay I was
talking about how uh
on set he's the guy that works in cruise
on movie sets Okay and he's talking
about how
he people get a close to him too close
to him sometimes yeah and he says and he
has he's relaying the story to me he's
like he's like and I'm just like get out
of my rice bowl
and I was like I was like wait what does
it mean what did you just say and he was
like get out of my rice ball I was like
I was like I don't know what that means
man like what are you talking about he's
like you know like
you're someone's like up in your rice
bowl I guess it kind of makes sense I
was like you got your own Bowl that's
racist though oh maybe I mean if there's
an Asian trying to interrupt you that's
what I'm saying like it's just like why
are you adding in an effort into my
burrito but make sure there's no
Mexicans around right well that's what I
mean like why are you asking my pizza
get out of my get out of my space just
say that right it's like rice ball I'm
gonna do Rice okay get out of my rice
bowl
I guess the right spot isn't necessarily
an Asian
dishes yeah Cuisine but why right out of
my cream of some young guy why rice
it's not a Wayne's World yeah dude
remember Wayne's World cream of some
young god wow dude Wayne's World is
hilarious I know dude wow
ah [__] remember when Rob Lowe would do
the thing and he spoke to me he's like I
I speak Cantonese remember that yeah
dude we're we're
off the rails but yeah okay that's good
for the weed thing yeah we should have
people send in those their things oh I'm
afraid that they won't be that good but
like because you you really need to be
there for the thing yeah but but I'm
afraid people need to sell it if they're
gonna say they really need to if you're
gonna do it do it but sell it yeah don't
just be someone else like one time they
could do it yeah you might as well send
them in all right cool now here's the
thing before we get to the next one I'm
in the middle of a rook now oh yeah the
first part done on Friday got my last
part done yesterday my next Parts my
last part's doing Thursday but guess
what today I'm in immense pain all right
let's do the next one dude what why is
there three levels it's not a video game
no it's because it's because they can't
do it all at once it's like too much to
do time wise no no no no although that
would probably wise yeah what yeah yeah
how long were you in this uh about two
hours both times
crazy
are you what's the pain level with your
mouth right now yeah I can get you
something just like this
three if I'm talking five of them eating
like wow hitting the top of the thing I
can get you some oxycon
rice bowl is a thing oh I got the
giggles bro yeah what does it say it
says a task performed by a specific
individual group
or a protected job project program Etc
oh well then why didn't you excuse me an
example I don't need Jim I can change
the tire myself but Bob you got to get
let Jim fix it that's his Rice Bowl
oh why didn't he explain it better oh he
used the term wrong though he's not even
he doesn't know what the term is no it
sounds like he was doing the right the
right get out of my rice bowl because
you're talking too close to me that's
wrong yeah well unless sorry you know if
you met you're saying if you meant it
like get out of my domain right yeah
okay yeah right job right well he
certainly didn't explain that to me so
but maybe he doesn't know how it's used
it he knows it wrong and he just does it
whenever
knowing him that is extremely likely
right got it yeah yeah yeah uh
great guy though
well what was I going to say God damn it
I had another root canal or what
right now I can get you some oxygen
right now about a five I'm good man
thank you because it's addictive highly
addictive it is and there's a huge thing
going on in 1996 to like 2000 I mean
it's kind of stuff no but yeah but
Oxycontin was the thing it's huge it's
hero usually still going it's heroin
fentanyl is a hundred times I know a
thousand times stronger than morphine
which is even stronger than oxycon 100
times even possible Oxycontin is a
hundred times more potent than morphine
so really yeah damn and so they oh dude
because I've been watching the thing you
know oh actually everything on it like I
watched painkiller then I watch dope
second then I watch the documentaries I
saw all this [__] but man it is so crazy
that they thought dude there's a time
release
thing it's yeah I know yeah and they
were like well the good thing is the
dose doesn't go into you
it goes into you it releases as you need
it for 12 hours right but dude you put
it in your mouth and you swallow it and
then it releases do people were just
snorting it yeah and that obviously
that's a way to get Beyond it okay
is that obvious I guess I wouldn't it is
when somebody decides to do it and then
they just spread the information right
okay you know the company's new dude
that [__] that it blows my mind dude
okay but you know what I mean Oxycontin
but we're doing this now and I'm just
saying but Oxycontin is crazy how that
[__] went as far as I control now it's
fentanyl yes did you ever see the videos
of the cop that are like let's see what
we got here they open a bag and then
they're just like are those real I hate
when people say that but I've seen that
and I don't know if those are real a
fentanyl a little piece of fentanyl go
like it's like the uh Forest gum feather
you're just at the park
playing with your kids
[Music]
you know why did we blend those together
[Laughter]
why are those together I know I know
what else floats the bag in American
Beauty you could pick whatever you want
but dude a [__] dope fiend dude in
the park in a library three they don't
even use libraries anymore three blocks
away
this guy over here outside the cuckoo
gets lucky
just talking to his friends
kids on the swing yeah and they brush
that's not what happened dude you know
what I mean if that happened it would
never be made ever you know what
happened to my kid it's not gonna happen
no three blocks away outside the library
no a milligram of fentanyl can kill you
though for sure see if you don't use it
ever if you've never used it before well
a kid never uses it your kid a kid a kid
oh I see what you're saying that's not
what happens though it doesn't float
through the air and then go into his
nose and then he dies which is not this
is not a thing you know
all right all right next one for real
the guy in the car getting away okay
dude this guy is on one second of coke
it it is one second immediately are you
so yaked out yeah and the cops are
following him and it's unreal dude he's
in Florida he hasn't slept in 70 days
he's definitely in Florida
70 hours sorry 70 days 70 hours
[Laughter]
it's all incredible yeah yeah I do just
cook on his lip right there yeah he does
all right
I'm at the beach so don't judge me uh
but anyway I had a moment today that
made me laugh and I'm like oh my God you
guys are rubbing off on me for sure
through the podcast
um there were these two women that were
like talking really loudly having this I
killed a private conversation but like
around everybody else talking about
money how much they're making the drama
at work all the stuff that's like you
know you at first I was like oh I'm
gonna like try to not listen and then I
was like
F that I was like I'm going to I'm going
to listen harder now I'm going to get
closer yeah I'm gonna I might even chime
in yeah you know what I mean I might
even oh really really 80 000. oh crazy
that's that's wild you know what I mean
and I was like this is something that
maybe Chris and Matt would do so anyway
maybe the question would be what do you
all do when people are talking and
having like private conversations in
public thanks guys you rock so hold on
so this guy did he actually say stuff to
them him yeah I don't think so okay so
he just got closer listen so I
understand that also I cannot believe
how much he would be in [__] movies
in 2002 yeah with that face bro third
lead you missed it in an indie about
like kids who said green no and we were
Seth Green by mistake ended up driving a
car with drugs in the trunk
wow that's the and crossing the border
that is the most that is
that is one of the best calls ever on
Lifeline that's unreal this Scott Khan
would be in it too that is unreal that
is on
that is UN [__] real that that
that that that call that guy would be in
a movie yeah that would oh wow 2003.
and there's so many flannels in that
movie yeah but yeah dude puka shell oh
yeah you know yeah you know he didn't
even have a boogie shot necklace on but
he did yeah I agree yeah so what do we
do
I I mean I I tell you what I people that
I'm with get really annoyed with me
because I'll be like to them
because I want to listen to the people
that I don't know that are being too
loud yeah and I find I actually
completely understand why they get mad
at me for that because that is so
annoying if I'm talking and someone
tells me to shoot yeah because they want
to listen to strangers I would be mad
too but I I can't help it I love love
love love listening to strangers I have
binoculars at home I Spy on neighbors I
kind of that's illegal no I have it is
illegal but they've never caught me so
okay you do the math okay I live in a
house that's kind of like looking down
okay this is illegal until like not a
canyon but the homes are like beneath
yes on on the streets below I'm just
like this okay so it's illegal looking
into Windows looking into bedrooms yeah
telescope no I don't want to get a
telescope okay well too clunky you got
to be able to run
you got to be able to run away
yeah you can't do that
[Laughter]
I mean you know sexual [__] what was the
what was that you know when you let the
tripod down with the things
the air comes out yeah yeah
dude you run into the Fentanyl and you
die okay so um
I guess
oh there you know sometimes you know
what I do that is the truth and
this is just like that is when I'm in
line
and there's somebody that is too close
behind me
okay because it happens we were like
what this is so close right yeah yeah I
back up very slowly yeah that's good
into them
until I'm touching them that's good and
I wait for them to move that's good good
job and then and because it's it's not
really that confrontational it's
effective I'm sure but it's not like
turn around say hey excuse me can you
back up I want in my fantasy I want them
to be like what are you doing
and then you do what and I say oh I'm
sorry I didn't realize you were so close
that's good yeah because then
they get it they might get it on the
ride home like oh [__] I was too close I
love that you're counting on them
getting it and that's what you like
about it I have a fantasy this is above
any sexual fantasy above any Victory
fantasy above any career fantasy I have
a fantasy
I have a fantasy that I think of all the
time oh boy okay and I won't stop
thinking of it because I can't yeah okay
I get that yeah
my eyes
fall upon oh some Man's Shoes
and I like them I like his shoes okay
and I catch them and I'm watching and I
look at his shoes that dude walks up to
me and says yo man what the [__] are you
looking at right and then I say oh I was
just admiring your shoes uh-huh and
that's the fantasy that's it yeah that's
the whole fantasy bro I think about it
all the time what is the what what even
is that because I want that guy oh do
you think that I'm a like get pissed off
and then realize he's the [__] I mean
if someone got pissed at that they'd be
such an ass I know but then I compliment
them even if you had something shitty to
say I always say I was admiring your
shoes admiring I always I'm gonna you
don't always say that you've never done
it this has never happened in my fantasy
I always want to be clear about that
yeah it's never happened I think about
it do you go around staring at people's
shoes no but well I mean I I definitely
look at people's shoes because I like
shoes right right so that's something
then you should do that you should try
it out stare at people's shoes more even
if you don't like them just get that
fantasy I don't think it'll ever be as
good as the fantasy oh wow protecting
yourself okay protecting your dreams I I
legit think about that at least I would
a few times a month I think about that
you're crazy you're in the same person
is that crazy it's just not a thing
that's not a thing yeah people have
fantasies of like having sex with twins
and [__] not me dude I mean I you know I
I've had those fantasies I've done it
but I'm just saying I haven't done that
but I'm just saying I've been on the
shoot I haven't done the shoe thing
either no and she gets stepping I one
time I was in line I used to love the
sandwiches at Vons at the counter this
is a fantasy those are real there's a
guy that was too close to me from behind
me and then I was putting my stuff on
them yeah and the guy that was too close
behind me went like this like this say
this is my sandwich anyone like this huh
oh no you got it at the counter no yeah
touch my [__]
and I couldn't believe it I was so in
disbelief I I hit it out of his hand
really yeah dude how old are you oh this
was like I was in my 20s okay so hold on
so obviously the sandwich is wrapped up
of course yeah but that's still crazy
it's still so crazy that's so weird to
touch something that like gives and it's
soft like this and I hit a hit I was
gonna say don't [__] touch my food
any any if I [__] was [__] up
because he immediately went oh oh oh I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry and I realized
he like has boundary issues oh so you're
a bad guy I like triggered him yeah
you're a bad guy yeah like he was
obviously Autistic or something and
you're a bad person I don't know what it
was but some could have been Asperger's
because he didn't realize
I didn't realize the boundary he didn't
realize the battery was crossing yeah
and when I did that he felt actually bad
oh and then I was like oh no I'm sorry I
just was like my insta oh my God you
know what Krista would have done oh here
I have it have a sandwich what else do
you want to buy open your mouth open
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah open it shoot
my titties here here's some [__]
um here's some [__]
uh
um anyway yeah all right yeah a little
more yeah cool
guys okay I need advice I'm starting
school next week and I'm already kind of
nervous about it but I read my like
reviews for my professors and my math
teacher has horrible reviews like
horrible everything one is like the
lowest rating and they all say she's
really mean and everybody fails her
class
just like not a good teacher so my
question is do I go in like kissing her
ass like do I bring cookies or something
or do I go in with more of like a don't
[__] with me Vibe I don't think that
don't [__] with Levi is going to work
because I don't really naturally give
that vibe off but I don't know dude I'm
just
spitballing here so whatever you got
please help go on with go in the
room with sunglasses and be blaring this
I mean the solution to everything
no see I don't know I don't I don't know
why I don't know what makes me this way
but when I read I'm not in school
anymore but like when I read reviews of
a thing before I experience it for
myself you can review teachers that's
crazy I always always always
think these are not right I'll figure it
out yeah it is true though because so
much of it depends on how you are yeah
it does right the person to react in the
way that they're being described in the
reviews but what you're saying is very
true you cannot take an online review
seriously yeah you can't do it even if
there's hundreds of them you don't this
could have become a thing and then
people hate and then they make a thing
and then totally yeah dude truthfully so
what I was what I would suggest is go in
the first day like you would anything
yeah yeah you pay close attention
what can often happen is if you're aware
that
you know the teacher is usually hates
her students or his students or whatever
uh you can if you want to be be the one
that they don't hate pretty easily
because you can just observe what
they're hating about all the other
students and be a different way at least
in the 50 minutes that you're in front
of them for it's not hard to be a kid a
teacher likes you know if you want if
that's something you care about you know
uh but yeah I
mean teachers
so what that's when people were like
like when Ellen everyone's like take
Ellen down it's like why she's a mean
boss dude bosses are mean
teachers you know what I mean it's like
yeah there are good teachers and there
are nice bosses but dude
oh well actually sorry Ellen's mean but
I would say no [__] she's mean we get no
[__] she's one of the richest people in
the world of course she's [__] Super
Famous of course she's mean exactly uh
thank you but and chill the [__] out but
this is different because she's not
trying to no no I know like I'm nervous
I know I know uh I bet she's not as bad
as she's not you're making it a
romanticizing it and also
means just heightening it
it's not like you're gonna go in there
kiss her sweep her off her feet darling
Hi how are you I heard you're mean but I
don't believe any of it now is the word
mush
here's some cookies wow here's an apple
ew
don't do that you've done that before I
do it all the time I don't want you to
do it that's what you do when you kiss
no okay well it is but
no one wants to see that you know there
are probably some people maybe some but
not most people don't look I'm about to
do it look away all right but I gotta do
this too because I don't want to hear it
either
all right
see hearing it's even grosser to be
honest uh
yeah I don't know you're all right man
it's gonna be fine and also who cares if
she's mean yeah you know what I'm saying
it's all about the work it's about to
work right because here's the other
thing too I used to get pissed off
whoops I used to get pissed off at
hecklers
I used to get pissed off at them
genuinely during the show and my friend
was like dude
careful with that because you're just
exacerbating what's happening it's it's
a ripple effect of a negative of
negativity for everybody else there
right so like a haircut stands up says
something they ruin the show
yeah me getting pissed off about it and
I don't even be putting it on a place
but just having that in my head that
negativity it's lessening the show for
everyone yeah okay you I've got to drop
that if I'm truly about it when they
Heckle I'm like do not do that you're
ruining for everyone else if I'm truly
about that life yeah then I got to be
truly about the
home life when I'm on stage but also
still killing right okay so many things
you know so many lives to be about
um
yeah
yeah it's gonna be fine you're gonna be
fine but first advice don't like I just
don't go into it being a different
person than you are that's gonna get you
in trouble in all scenarios always go
away and be yourself pay close attention
to the teacher
and decide for yourself if she's going
to be a problem or he's going to be
great or whatever totally you know oh by
the way I want to be in Charlotte coming
up here and I'm going to be in Little
Rock Arkansas and your boy's going to be
in Knoxville and Nashville and Canada
crystalia.com for tickets so that's it
mattelier.com for one-on-one sessions
with me your boy pimpin pimpin
get in there oh make an appointment with
me yeah we'll probably very likely save
your life but no guarantee okay well
that yeah maybe not there's a comedy
podcast but uh go to the patreon
lifeline luxury patreon.com Lifeline
luxury it's great it's growing it's
awesome and we do at least two episodes
extra a month uh and they've just been
firing all over the place man they've
been really just coming and Blasting all
over the place
um if you have a question just click the
uh description and we got a hotline and
also uh go to the the email thing and um
that's it we also have merch uh
lifelinemerch.com
and that's it I appreciate you guys like
And subscribe baby
[Music]